Secretary of State James Madison in
Afghanistan overnight for a surprise
pardon me Secretary of Defense for a
surprise visit Secretary of Defense
mattis he's meeting with US military
commanders overseeing America's longest
war and Afghan President Ashraf Ghani
Charlie d'Agata has covered the conflict
in Afghanistan over the past decade he's
in Kabul on a week-long reporting trip
Charlie good morning good morning well
the defense Secretary's visit here not
only comes on the same week of a new
terrorist attack here in Kabul that
killed more than 20 people but on the
week that a u.s. servicemen died in an
insider attack that followed another
insider attack in July Afghan President
Ashraf Ghani told us commanders here
today
preventing green-on-blue attacks as
they're called is a top national
priority Isis has claimed responsibility
for the twin bombings of the Sports
Centre that happened on the day we
arrived US forces are at the forefront
of a coalition effort to train Afghan
forces not only to fight Isis but a
resurgent Taliban which has not only
reclaimed territory that US forces
fought and died for but continues to hit
targets here in the capital the defense
Secretary's visit also coincides with a
change of leadership of the US military
and that may assure in a change of
tactics here Nora an important trip
Charlie d'Agata inside Afghanistan thank
you